Caption: hello everybody
Caption: i am dr felicity millman and i want to
Caption: share with you some reasons we should
Caption: begin to consider rethinking artificial
Caption: intelligence and our automated systems
Caption: to begin to understand some of the
Caption: unintended consequences
Caption: but before i do
Caption: i want to say a giant thank you to our
Caption: wonderful sponsors who are helping us be
Caption: here today wherever you are physically
Caption: virtually any time of day or night thank
Caption: you
Caption: and i wanted to let you know a little
Caption: bit about me to begin
Caption: i originally did a phd in psychology and
Caption: genetics which turns out means i'm a bit
Caption: of a data nurse um and transitioning
Caption: from there i have recently a couple of
Caption: years ago i went and got a masters in
Caption: cybernetics which basically means
Caption: artificial intelligence and how we think
Caption: about it
Caption: went on to work in the cyber security
Caption: institute as a threat caster which means
Caption: i work to try and understand where our
Caption: future threats are going to come from
Caption: and how we should mitigate them and
Caption: these days i also do a little bit of
Caption: teaching
Caption: innovation
Caption: um for engineering and computer science
Caption: as well as building cyber security
Caption: simulations that are actually inclusive
Caption: for everyone not just the cyber security
Caption: professionals but government people
Caption: policy people your admin people
Caption: everywhere for the national security
Caption: college at anu
Caption: so
Caption: from that
Caption: given that we're all on country
Caption: somewhere i want to say
Caption: a big acknowledgement to the traditional
Caption: custodians of the land that i'm standing
Caption: on at the moment so that is the wajak
Caption: people of the noongar nation as well as
Caption: others in other places around us there
Caption: are so many to name that
Caption: but thank you and acknowledging
Caption: so
Caption: why do we need to think about artificial
Caption: intelligence and what actually happens
Caption: with it well
Caption: i imagine when we think of technology
Caption: and in general we don't always think of
Caption: where it's going to go
Caption: so i imagine when the first steam
Caption: engines were built they didn't quite
Caption: accidentally think that they might cause
Caption: climate change
Caption: by basically fueling their engines with
Caption: fossilized trees and bits of animal
Caption: bones they didn't realize that
Caption: create systems that would include huge
Caption: amounts of pollution but yes we get
Caption: pretty cool cars out of it
Caption: we also look at things like drones we
Caption: think awesome i get to take some really
Caption: cool photos personally i am a drone
Caption: lover i have done this myself but it
Caption: also enables us to have some quite scary
Caption: weapons like the one you can see in my
Caption: hand there as well as the big drones
Caption: they have or the swarms of drones that
Caption: currently our technical systems
Caption: struggle to manage and that
Caption: perhaps not too re not too long ago
Caption: um
Caption: and we also have things like our
Caption: satellite technology
Caption: dear older elon musk put a few up
Caption: recently and when i say i mean a lot and
Caption: while that's great it's connecting
Caption: people all over the globe it's actually
Caption: kind of causing a few problems for our
Caption: astronomers who aren't actually able
Caption: to pictures that they want to take to be
Caption: able to understand where our world has
Caption: come from bit of a problem there
Caption: so i guess it kind of makes us think
Caption: technology is neither good nor bad
Caption: i think most people have kind of
Caption: understood that but the one thing we
Caption: often do forget is technology is not
Caption: either
Caption: so when we think of artificial
Caption: intelligence one of the things we often
Caption: think about is data mining it's how you
Caption: make a lot of machine learning types of
Caption: systems you actually extract value from
Caption: the you create
Caption: now
Caption: it's it really is an extracted process
Caption: data mining is is important
Caption: something that we actually do well in
Caption: western australia and australia in
Caption: general is mining we do it well
Caption: something that a lot of people don't
Caption: realize about western australia is we
Caption: actually have one of the most enduring
Caption: histories of mining on the planet i'm
Caption: not just talking you know a couple of
Caption: thousand years i'm talking a really long
Caption: time
Caption: hey this is something we can actually
Caption: learn from
Caption: so this is wiljumia it's a couple
Caption: hundred kilometers out of mount magnet
Caption: it's in the it's in the middle of
Caption: western australia it's a beautiful
Caption: beautiful place but it's actually over
Caption: 30 000 years old it is the world one of
Caption: the world's oldest mines it has been
Caption: used continuously
Caption: for 30 years
Caption: think of that the people who
Caption: have been doing this
Caption: created one of the largest networks on
Caption: the planet they learned how to extract
Caption: value from the ground
Caption: and to transmit it and pass it between
Caption: people and culture and to use it they
Caption: also created
Caption: some really really ingenious early
Caption: safety systems where they would ensure
Caption: that people had different layers so they
Caption: could extract data from different places
Caption: by having different pile systems they
Caption: actually built
Caption: structures to ensure that people the
Caption: rocks weren't caving in and falling on
Caption: them it was pretty impressive when you
Caption: think about it and they also used
Caption: regulations to ensure that their people
Caption: in their community weren't going to be
Caption: harmed so they actually had rules about
Caption: who could go in who wasn't allowed in
Caption: when they could go in and how
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: later and when we think about mining
Caption: this is a really really good place to
Caption: talk about it
Caption: we also have the largest robot
Caption: on the planet
Caption: so the auto whole system by rio tinto is
Caption: actually huge if you've ever been
Caption: fortunate enough to see it
Caption: is an automated system
Caption: mining is something we do well whether
Caption: it's been historically in the past or
Caption: currently right here right now in this
Caption: space this is something we do
Caption: let's kind of begin to understand a
Caption: little bit better
Caption: what are we actually looking at when
Caption: we're talking about automated systems
Caption: and cyber cyber physical systems
Caption: we know that everything is a has a
Caption: context we know that they're systems
Caption: where is the human labor in all these
Caption: artificial intelligence systems
Caption: sometimes we don't talk about that we
Caption: also don't talk about
Caption: sometimes
Caption: where the physical resources are
Caption: how we're actually extracting value out
Caption: of data and how do we make sense of it
Caption: so
Caption: when we think about it
Caption: as i said how do we make sense of it
Caption: well
Caption: one of the first questions i think it's
Caption: important to ask is what is artificial
Caption: intelligence
Caption: a lot of the time when i talk to
Caption: technical people they will give me some
Caption: variation of data and networks and how
Caption: we put them together and there's a model
Caption: and these things are all technical and
Caption: they're right
Caption: however it's not the only thing
Caption: this doesn't come out of nowhere
Caption: there are networks there are cultures
Caption: and contexts where this stuff is all
Caption: coming from
Caption: so i actually think it's important that
Caption: we recognize systems create artificial
Caption: intelligence and our machine learning
Caption: systems
Caption: and they are actually
Caption: cyber physical systems when we put these
Caption: things together
Caption: we're talking about a whole structure of
Caption: people and places places and objects in
Caption: a time and place
Caption: so
Caption: going back to how we make sense of it
Caption: do we actually look at a component or do
Caption: we look at the system
Caption: a lot of the time when we talk about
Caption: artificial intelligence i will hear
Caption: people tell me about chips and how much
Caption: storage they have and how much
Caption: processing they have
Caption: we are really exquisitely good at taking
Caption: a microscopic view
Caption: we go down into the tiny tiny tiny tiny
Caption: tiny tiny details
Caption: to figure out how somethings works
Caption: sometimes it might be useful to take
Caption: step back
Caption: of a telescope try and look out what
Caption: system is this part of how does it
Caption: connect to everything else
Caption: i think it's important to remember
Caption: everything has a history and everything
Caption: has a context so when we're looking at
Caption: systems we need to look at when we're
Caption: looking at
Caption: machine learning
Caption: intelligence we need to try and
Caption: understand where they come from
Caption: so
Caption: again it's looking at cyber physical
Caption: systems
Caption: one of the big questions i like to ask
Caption: is how something comes into being how
Caption: does it made where does it come from
Caption: why was it made
Caption: one of the big questions i always look
Caption: at is physical resources and again
Caption: that's not talking just about your
Caption: network cables
Caption: and your hardware and your chips it's
Caption: actually talking about how they're
Caption: connected
Caption: so
Caption: i think this is important because the
Caption: connection points can actually hint
Caption: where the inherent value is in the
Caption: system how we actually understand what
Caption: we're extracting what are we actually
Caption: using here
Caption: one of the best examples i've ever seen
Caption: of this was going back in history a
Caption: little bit and looking at how our
Caption: original networks were made so these
Caption: were the sub c cables which were
Caption: connecting all through the globe
Caption: connecting telegraphs
Caption: now on the screen you can actually see
Caption: their
Caption: cutout sections of the original network
Caption: cables
Caption: so
Caption: how are they made probably not something
Caption: most people think about
Caption: turns out
Caption: the original subsea cables just like our
Caption: modern cables required insulation
Caption: because you know seawater degrades
Caption: things you know
Caption: um it's something that
Caption: previous generations actually had to
Caption: grapple with
Caption: turns out one of the best things they
Caption: could insulate with
Caption: was tree sap so from the good of percher
Caption: tray because it's naturally
Caption: thermoplastic so when you heat it up
Caption: it's all melty and when you cool it down
Caption: it's quite rigid and stable that's kind
Caption: of cool kind of interesting so that um
Caption: kind of happened around
Caption: 18 20 18 30. they begin to figure out oh
Caption: we've got something
Caption: so one of the things about this trade
Caption: this very special tree is it actually
Caption: takes 30 years to reach maturity andre
Caption: it's kind of interesting we've got some
Caption: old trades around 30 years doesn't seem
Caption: that much
Caption: but
Caption: how much sap do you think a tree
Caption: makes for one tree
Caption: not even a kilogram
Caption: of their sap
Caption: so these blocks are some of the original
Caption: blocks that were from the good of percha
Caption: tree when it was processed they cut them
Caption: all up effectively boil them then they
Caption: process them so they get off the stuff
Caption: that's not actually the sap
Caption: and they turn them in into these blocks
Caption: that they then would extrude over the
Caption: actual cables
Caption: so
Caption: just in this time frame just a year
Caption: three hundred and nine three thousand
Caption: nine
Caption: three thousand nine hundred and sixty
Caption: nautical miles of cable were late
Caption: and that was about 181 kilos of good
Caption: aperture
Caption: so if you do the math
Caption: that's one point two million trees
Caption: three hundred trees per nautical mile
Caption: in the hundred years that this stuff was
Caption: predominantly used
Caption: there were three well just this is just
Caption: one set of cabling 315 nautical miles of
Caption: cable we used
Caption: equated to 47 million
Caption: trees
Caption: and that's a conservative estimate
Caption: that's if we actually have the amount of
Caption: um good a purchase they used on each
Caption: cable in case they'll be using some thin
Caption: sections some thick sections so chances
Caption: are over 100 million of these trays
Caption: were used
Caption: by one company
Caption: in one country
Caption: that isn't even all the cables run
Caption: across the planet
Caption: so
Caption: guess what guys we made one of the
Caption: earliest human
Caption: made disasters at human ecologically
Caption: human-made disasters
Caption: building our technological systems
Caption: now
Caption: how did it come into being
Caption: we made it
Caption: we also need to recognize that when i
Caption: say these connection points hint at the
Caption: inherent value in the system
Caption: human labor was also involved
Caption: so there were workers in predominantly
Caption: malaysia and borneo who were going out
Caption: and cutting down these trees
Caption: and try initially trying to actually
Caption: drain the sap out of them and logging
Caption: them and bringing them to ships and
Caption: ports all over the globe there were
Caption: little kids in factories often in
Caption: england
Caption: who were cutting this stuff up working
Caption: with boiling tree sap not a nice job
Caption: many of these people weren't paid
Caption: particularly much money and historically
Caption: if we look at where the value went it
Caption: was not to the workers nor was it to the
Caption: people whose land these trades would
Caption: take from
Caption: so
Caption: we know that a lot of these cables
Caption: were actually made to strategic points
Caption: of strategic intake
Caption: importance for colonies so where these
Caption: cables were being laid weren't
Caption: necessarily going back to the people
Caption: who's
Caption: been cut down they were often going
Caption: between
Caption: europe and america
Caption: and various europeans
Caption: so even though we were taking all these
Caption: wonderful trees and making these amazing
Caption: systems
Caption: the value was not necessarily where we
Caption: thought it would have been
Caption: but it hints at the value that we was
Caption: actually present in the system and how
Caption: it directed how it was actually built
Caption: so worthwhile considering when you're
Caption: building
Caption: technological systems
Caption: our cables and those values were not
Caption: distributed evenly
Caption: worthwhile considering
Caption: so
Caption: the decisions of those people in the
Caption: past are still impacting
Caption: us today
Caption: those network cables impact who has
Caption: actual internet connection to this very
Caption: very day we're in western australia and
Caption: i'm sure many of you will have either
Caption: been in mining or dealt with mining or i
Caption: had to go out bush for some reason
Caption: trying to get internet connection out
Caption: bush
Caption: not fun
Caption: a couple of months ago i was driving out
Caption: to go on holiday and had the unfortunate
Caption: experience of getting
Caption: 60 kilometers out of perth before i
Caption: realized that i needed internet
Caption: connection to connect my sat phone turns
Caption: out i actually gotta use the internet to
Caption: connect a sat phone and if you drive too
Caption: far out can't do that
Caption: so those decisions far back then
Caption: impacted my ability on this to this very
Caption: very day based on where we've got
Caption: connection points and we've chosen to
Caption: build our systems
Caption: so
Caption: recognizing again our technological
Caption: systems
Caption: have created ecological disasters they
Caption: have exploited traditional knowledge
Caption: but at the same time they were the
Caption: foundations of the industrial revolution
Caption: they've enabled us innovation they've
Caption: enabled us to be here right today this
Caption: very moment talking to you in this room
Caption: talking to you wherever you are sitting
Caption: on this planet
Caption: technology isn't good or bad
Caption: but it does come very very very well in
Caption: transition values
Caption: so what about again human labor i don't
Caption: know how many people here have heard the
Caption: story of the mechanical turk
Caption: fair while ago
Caption: there was
Caption: um
Caption: a person who decided he'd built a box
Caption: and had told people that it could
Caption: magically play chess
Caption: without a human involved and it was
Caption: carted around europe
Caption: and said to be this amazing invention
Caption: because it could play chess
Caption: however
Caption: turns out
Caption: that what was actually inside
Caption: it
Caption: was a machine partially
Caption: but the machine actually contained a
Caption: very small human who was a grand test
Caption: master who could actually move the
Caption: little dials
Caption: inside so
Caption: the mechanical turk and i admit hideous
Caption: name but it's historically what the name
Caption: is
Caption: kind of showed people wait a second some
Caption: of our technical systems we think
Caption: are artificially intelligent that we
Caption: think a mechanical that we think it's
Caption: smart
Caption: have people involved
Caption: where is it
Caption: where's it hidden
Caption: and often it is hidden
Caption: so
Caption: amazon's mechanical turk system the
Caption: reason it is called mturk is from
Caption: mechanical turk because what it actually
Caption: is is humans all around the globe who
Caption: aren't paid particularly may i say
Caption: competitive laborious and boring tasks
Caption: for a very very cheap price which often
Caption: startups not looking at anybody in the
Caption: room
Caption: build or they they actually use the m
Caption: turks system these tasks done of which
Caption: they then suggest it is actually
Caption: artificial intelligence it's just a
Caption: human hidden somewhere else
Caption: to make these systems work
Caption: um
Caption: we also have situations
Caption: where you are the human labor
Caption: how often do we actually think about
Caption: the capture systems that we use
Caption: because again
Caption: that is you training an artificial
Caption: intelligence system object recognition
Caption: often how to identify an object are you
Caption: valuing your time
Caption: the company certainly is and often these
Caption: are already used on websites and
Caption: services which you pay to use
Caption: calling out paypal
Caption: they certainly use object they certainly
Caption: use capture again they call it a
Caption: security feature but you're already
Caption: getting charged in one sense you're
Caption: getting charged again in your labor
Caption: it's a choice that's being made
Caption: again it's hidden they're not actually
Caption: acknowledging that is what is happening
Caption: here
Caption: we also have again our really really
Caption: large companies facebook google amazon
Caption: we certainly know or i'm sure many
Caption: people have heard the stories of the
Caption: amazon workers who are actually working
Caption: in warehouses who are picking and
Caption: packing those objects that all of us
Caption: have kind of ordered given we're in the
Caption: middle of a pandemic many people have
Caption: ordered things online because it's easy
Caption: fair enough
Caption: but the people are actually getting them
Caption: are real humans who actually have to
Caption: work to a very very specific clock the
Caption: point
Caption: being so specific that they actually
Caption: expect high rates of injury because the
Caption: humans have to work to the machine not
Caption: the machines working to the humans or
Caption: their abilities which is kind of scary
Caption: when you think about it all your data
Caption: you put on facebook and what you put on
Caption: google again these are used to train
Caption: artificially intelligent systems that is
Caption: your human labor is it valued
Caption: also got data content moderators
Caption: and data classification systems
Caption: what about the extraction process so how
Caption: do we get
Caption: we know that like okay we can get some
Caption: data that's great
Caption: where does it come from
Caption: and how they influence us
Caption: so
Caption: we know our machine learning models are
Caption: actually built from data
Caption: it has come from somewhere
Caption: as i said where does the data come from
Caption: and where are those choices hidden
Caption: let's talk about natural language
Caption: processing because you know that's an
Caption: easy topic we use words words are
Caption: important
Caption: if you actually look back in history
Caption: some of the oldest language uh
Caption: oldest nlp models and the oldest data
Caption: sex sets actually come from
Caption: legal battles
Caption: so 19 ibm's 1969 13-year legal battle
Caption: and enron's bankruptcy proceedings have
Caption: actually been used to train a lot of our
Caption: natural language processing systems so
Caption: again if you trace things like gpt
Caption: threes data modeling back and back and
Caption: back and back and back you actually get
Caption: to some of these places where some of
Caption: the raw input was initially put in
Caption: we have a criteria
Caption: when we use these systems
Caption: do you think the way that you speak in
Caption: the way that i speak reflects the words
Caption: that are in those legal battles
Caption: i don't think i speak like a legal
Caption: person at all times i imagine i probably
Caption: don't
Caption: not only because i'm australian and
Caption: let's be honest we have a tendency for
Caption: profanity
Caption: um
Caption: but because we also have our own culture
Caption: our own jargon that doesn't necessarily
Caption: match the ones that have been used
Caption: we're repeatingly building on these
Caption: systems our models are getting better
Caption: and better and better and we're getting
Caption: further and further and further and
Caption: further away from some of these systems
Caption: knowing where they've come from
Caption: unfortunately the assumption with these
Caption: systems is language in them is
Caption: unbiased
Caption: and it's neutral
Caption: i would say it's probably
Caption: so
Caption: what can that actually do
Caption: when we start looking at these systems
Caption: if we put automated systems in to say
Caption: challenge if somebody is being rude or
Caption: is it hate speech
Caption: it can often penalize people who don't
Caption: come from the same background as where
Caption: the data has been trained so if you
Caption: happen to be
Caption: a bit of a sweary pants sorry some
Caption: australians
Caption: or you happen to be from
Caption: black african american culture that one
Caption: certainly happened there tends to be
Caption: higher rates of flagging for hate speech
Caption: when it really if human moderators rate
Caption: it it's not hate speech this is a
Caption: different culture and a different
Caption: context that this information is
Caption: actually coming from
Caption: trying to begin to actually pull that
Caption: apart we need to actually understand
Caption: where is our data coming from
Caption: are we making sense of it
Caption: i think it's important to realize here
Caption: that standardized
Caption: does not mean objective
Caption: so just because a particular model might
Caption: be standardized doesn't mean it's
Caption: objective
Caption: so we may try and classify data by
Caption: saying that's a cat and that's a dog
Caption: that's a boat that's a pig
Caption: that's it's standardized it's not
Caption: necessarily objective
Caption: so
Caption: we know that we can look at the output
Caption: and say this is great
Caption: but where does the output come from
Caption: comes from a model which is built
Caption: from data
Caption: which that makes fair enough amount of
Caption: sense cool
Caption: but
Caption: who actually gets to classify those
Caption: images who gets to create the data
Caption: how do they do it
Caption: do you know
Caption: turns out a lot of the original data
Caption: sets go back to those people who are
Caption: working for a mechanical turk there are
Caption: other ones which go back in other
Caption: different ways but these people live in
Caption: different cultures different contexts
Caption: and different places
Caption: and have been portrayed
Caption: paid
Caption: again not necessarily very much to make
Caption: these decisions that impact our lives
Caption: right now
Caption: do you call someone young old
Caption: do you give them a race
Caption: how about assigning their identity for
Caption: them i wonder if they like that
Caption: worst of all hot or not back to mark
Caption: zuckerberg and his famous initial
Caption: experiment some of this stuff is being
Caption: done for us by people in different
Caption: places making decisions that impact our
Caption: lives
Caption: some of the
Caption: facial recognition data sets and some of
Caption: those that are actually used
Caption: by the us for their standardizing
Caption: situation by nist
Caption: um
Caption: unfortunately are actually made from
Caption: people who did not consent
Caption: often these people
Caption: many of them have actually died or were
Caption: deceased when they took the photos think
Caption: about that
Caption: and many of them were also convicted
Caption: criminals and these images were taken
Caption: over time
Caption: it gets a little bit creepy when you
Caption: think about that because they're devoid
Caption: of context and meaning and story and
Caption: personhood what we consider a criminal
Caption: now is not necessarily what was
Caption: considered criminal when some of these
Caption: voters were taken so unfortunately
Caption: people who may have
Caption: done something just as simple as being
Caption: gay was considered a criminal they've
Caption: ended up in a data set whether they're
Caption: whether that's okay or not we've not
Caption: looked at
Caption: certainly possible and it certainly
Caption: happens
Caption: we're beginning to shift the way that we
Caption: see images of data from single little
Caption: objects
Caption: to infrastructure these are a resource a
Caption: data set that we can all go in and use
Caption: apply for opportunity to download the
Caption: data set and train your model and off
Caption: you go without actually recognizing the
Caption: humans who are involved
Caption: what happens if these models
Caption: were built on your data
Caption: what about your baby photos it's kind of
Caption: cool
Caption: what about that really nice warming
Caption: brace you have with a friend
Caption: or the last photo you've got a grandma
Caption: before she died
Caption: would you like them to be classified and
Caption: who gets that choice
Caption: well
Caption: those photos are online chances are they
Caption: probably are already
Caption: into those things
Caption: so
Caption: all many object recognition systems are
Caption: providing the backbone of that cyber
Caption: physical system
Caption: and yet we are not making the decisions
Caption: or even considering
Caption: where the voice of the create creator is
Caption: what do your baby photos mean to you
Caption: what about a man's last photo
Caption: who's got the right to use them can
Caption: anybody use them
Caption: and how do they get to interpret them
Caption: what's actually interpreted
Caption: is grandma's photo one that's
Caption: tagged with love
Caption: or just
Caption: old woman world out hot or not starts
Caption: getting particularly creepy when you
Caption: think about it like that
Caption: everything has a history and a
Caption: context when we start
Caption: separating our history and context from
Caption: the data that we have and the systems
Caption: that we use
Caption: we lose a lot
Caption: a lot of the meaning goes by the wave
Caption: side and it actually shifts the systems
Caption: that we have
Caption: all around us
Caption: so what are the choices we're making and
Caption: how are they hidden
Caption: data does involve choices i hear a lot
Caption: of people tell me
Caption: it's okay it's standardized it's
Caption: objective
Caption: well i'd say it's not standardized i'd
Caption: say i'd say it's not objected objective
Caption: i'd say it's standardized
Caption: because we are making
Caption: life choices
Caption: which are
Caption: prioritizing one aspect in that photo
Caption: over another
Caption: it may be tagging
Caption: woman it may be tagging ocean it may be
Caption: tagging c
Caption: maybe tagging an emotion but man's
Caption: prioritizing something over another it
Caption: doesn't give the meaning in the context
Caption: these are excluded and things are
Caption: included and what is that he gets to
Caption: make that choice
Caption: it impacts us all
Caption: all those models when they build on the
Caption: data and the systems and the structures
Caption: they reflect those decisions straight
Caption: back to us
Caption: all of those photos i took i showed in
Caption: the previous example were not photos of
Caption: real people
Caption: they were actually photos from a gang
Caption: which actually created
Caption: people
Caption: if you go back and look at those photos
Caption: you'll notice most of them are of a
Caption: certain skin tone
Caption: and you'll also notice yeah
Caption: gender and culture
Caption: more commonalities than others
Caption: that doesn't necessarily reflect
Caption: humanity
Caption: that reflects the data that the system
Caption: was trained on
Caption: so
Caption: what we're looking at
Caption: is a lot of subjective choices that are
Caption: being made every day for us
Caption: again
Caption: everything has a history and everything
Caption: has a context
Caption: those cyber physical systems really are
Caption: systems they are structures there are
Caption: processes and people
Caption: we know these things are important
Caption: how can we adapt to them
Caption: i hear a lot of people getting quite
Caption: upset when they hear some of the awful
Caption: things that some of our artificially
Caption: intelligent or machine learning systems
Caption: can do from things like
Caption: uh deep fake
Caption: deep fake porn being one that is just
Caption: particularly creepy on a huge number of
Caption: levels
Caption: to
Caption: some really creepy twitter
Caption: kind of twitter creations where we have
Caption: bots who kind of swear back at us and do
Caption: some awful things
Caption: um
Caption: people say regulate it i love regulation
Caption: this is great we can just make it do not
Caption: do that because regulations will just
Caption: stop everything and while i really like
Caption: the idea kind of don't think it actually
Caption: works but even if it does well what are
Caption: we going to do we know these there's
Caption: things that we don't want our systems to
Caption: be
Caption: we don't want them to be
Caption: machine driven we don't want those
Caption: people in amazon warehouses having to
Caption: move exactly to the machine their entire
Caption: lives being driven by those machines
Caption: we know that we don't want our lives
Caption: controlled
Caption: by
Caption: machines around us or i certainly don't
Caption: we want trustworthy safe reliable
Caption: systems
Caption: so how do we build them
Caption: well
Caption: in australia at the moment we have an ai
Caption: ethics framework where some of these
Caption: values are stated how we build systems
Caption: and what should we be trying to build
Caption: them to
Caption: that seemed pretty fair to me i like the
Caption: idea
Caption: but
Caption: regulations just like our data just like
Caption: our models
Caption: are decisions
Caption: they're prior to people or they're
Caption: prioritizing
Caption: what is important for a certain group of
Caption: people at a certain place in time
Caption: they are not objective
Caption: the world is messy
Caption: it's complex and it's always in flux
Caption: things are changing you're changing i'm
Caption: changing i hope you all learn i hope the
Caption: person that you are yesterday is
Caption: different to the one you are tomorrow i
Caption: hope you're not the same person you were
Caption: when you were three because that'd be
Caption: weird
Caption: but
Caption: it's something we need to recognize the
Caption: world is messy it's complex
Caption: sort of cyber physical systems
Caption: how do we adapt them
Caption: well those regulations need to adapt to
Caption: changing systems
Caption: what is it within our regulations that
Caption: it allows us to go back and say well
Caption: you know we put in this rule
Caption: it didn't work very well maybe we could
Caption: try something else
Caption: we know that if we don't have enough
Caption: regulation it leads to harm and that's
Caption: how we end up with
Caption: uh some pretty dodgy system so i my mind
Caption: immediately goes to the d-flat porn
Caption: situation because it is just so
Caption: apparently awful um we know those things
Caption: can happen so we we don't do something
Caption: about it that's a really predictable
Caption: harm and we know we should probably do
Caption: something about that but the other thing
Caption: we need to recognize is over regulating
Caption: can actually cause some significant
Caption: problems too
Caption: it has the capacity to solidify
Caption: structures people processes and
Caption: decisions that aren't necessarily good
Caption: so i know that within the life span and
Caption: the living memory of people some of whom
Caption: may be here today
Caption: an indigenous person was not considered
Caption: a human
Caption: 1960 i think that was changed
Caption: it's kind of scary
Caption: certainly within my lifetime i think
Caption: being
Caption: gay lesbian lgbtqi
Caption: anything under that banner
Caption: was considered
Caption: actually an a an illness or a disease in
Caption: the diagnostic and statistical manual
Caption: for psychologists psychiatrists doctors
Caption: and it was made illegal in our legal
Caption: systems
Caption: so if we run regulations completely
Caption: solid and we don't recognize change we
Caption: can actually start putting in values in
Caption: place which maybe aren't so good for us
Caption: this
Caption: this also means we can over optimize
Caption: systems because i think a lot of the
Caption: time when we talk about regulations the
Caption: concept of regulation or rules
Caption: can go not just from the way that our
Caption: society makes decisions but how we build
Caption: companies and how we build teams and how
Caption: we build data sets
Caption: so
Caption: if all of your data sets
Caption: or all of your data comes from one
Caption: gender one age one particular skin tone
Caption: chances are if you try and release it in
Caption: a different place in the world that
Caption: system will break
Caption: or it will be biased or it will be just
Caption: flat out wrong
Caption: the same news for organizations people
Caption: governments regulations
Caption: if we actually only make systems that
Caption: can only take into account such a tiny
Caption: little thing systems break
Caption: we actually need flexibility in systems
Caption: we need
Caption: space for thinking we need diversity we
Caption: need people to have the opportunity to
Caption: see
Caption: difference
Caption: when we start making the reins of what
Caption: we do tighter and tighter and tighter
Caption: and tighter and tighter
Caption: we can actually cause harm
Caption: again
Caption: our systems are created
Caption: they're based on decisions that
Caption: prioritize
Caption: we change
Caption: so to our systems
Caption: let's actually try and make sense of the
Caption: change rather than pretend that it
Caption: doesn't happen
Caption: how do we do that
Caption: we bring in diversity
Caption: diversity actually straddles the line
Caption: between fragile and chaos we know our
Caption: systems need to be robust enough
Caption: that they can cope with a little bit of
Caption: change so we need rules and regulations
Caption: but they've got to be flexible enough
Caption: that they can take into account
Caption: unexpected changes because if we don't
Caption: we make dangerous things
Caption: when we're talking diversity we need
Caption: data ideas experiences and people
Caption: we need it at all levels
Caption: so why should this really matter to you
Caption: i'm here today
Caption: because most people think that's a
Caption: really nice idea i like diversity that's
Caption: great
Caption: um and yeah human labor makes an impact
Caption: on
Caption: what we build and yes sometimes it's
Caption: hidden and physical resources also
Caption: really count but why should it matter to
Caption: you
Caption: well
Caption: wa australia we are actually at the
Caption: epicentre of somewhere some of the
Caption: physical resources that build our cyber
Caption: physical systems
Caption: come from
Caption: so in w
Caption: in wa
Caption: we prese produce 41 percent of the
Caption: global supply of lithium
Caption: if you actually have
Caption: um a device that requires a little
Caption: battery
Caption: or you happen to be cool enough to have
Caption: your telstra
Caption: tesla car right we'll get the word out
Caption: um
Caption: what we're actually seeing is they
Caption: actually have lithium in the batteries
Caption: so all these systems require lithium
Caption: we actually supply that
Caption: many of these devices also require rare
Caption: earth metals
Caption: that comes
Caption: from right here in western australia
Caption: just as a bit of an aside one of the
Caption: major owners of one of the companies who
Caption: actually built some of this
Caption: is
Caption: an australian
Caption: mineral resources does a huge amount of
Caption: lithium mining owned by our
Caption: very own australian
Caption: who is making decisions
Caption: about where money is spent
Caption: what information is shared
Caption: who gets to hear what
Caption: these decisions matter
Caption: again
Caption: book
Caption: this is what happens when i click
Caption: buttons wrong sorry everybody
Caption: um
Caption: as technologists designers just general
Caption: citizens as people as regulators
Caption: you get to make choices that change this
Caption: world
Caption: and those tiny little choices about
Caption: what data's included are excluded which
Caption: models you use where does it come from
Caption: you can actually choose to make the
Caption: world better or not
Caption: that is up to you
Caption: so
Caption: how are the choices you're making
Caption: influencing the world
Caption: how are you looking at your human labor
Caption: and the human labor of the people who
Caption: contribute to these systems
Caption: how the environment the raw resources in
Caption: our own environment
Caption: impact on the supply chain that goes
Caption: along not just for us now but for people
Caption: in the future
Caption: where is it all hidden in the process
Caption: where is the feedback
Caption: how do we actually understand what
Caption: happens to these things because at the
Caption: moment these are discussions we don't
Caption: seem to have as often as maybe we could
Caption: i think it's worth
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]